[Music]
and what's up roommate news that was
Bart when he was living with my roommate
was a [ __ ] [ __ ] in the shower he will
leave the garage door open all the times
what's arrived or they don't even use
the garage okay and then he would have
like a [ __ ] jam session with Joe and
all the neighbors would be complaining
in the middle of the day not all the
names just one Asian man [ __ ] up the
dryer and you only live with us for like
a couple months too so this all dryer
how did you drop the dryer he forgot to
put the lint catcher in so one of my
thongs got caught in the motor oh my god
he was the one they [ __ ] hated him if
it did hit my guts like that friendship
with this [ __ ]
the single handedly because of our hey
that's incredible
what'd you do about the desire um did I
pay for the repairs we got us a long
time ago I don't remember but I think
Gio should have paid because of her
phone but I thought you know they're not
real people cuz like people are real
uppity [ __ ] I would have been really
funny like if someone fried my dryer cuz
I like crazy bus true if it was the only
and you can also buy a new dryer that's
the difference they could too
they were like yeah they were working
why should they have wait why would they
have roommates in I don't know try make
money uh no no it's not like I was a
accountant and the wife was a chemist
yeah but why should she have the why
should they have married dryer yeah
they're married oh they don't have to
but what I'm saying is like if you have
the comedy bug in you it's that's when
you can connect with people like for
example uh when when me and Jill like in
our first early years of living together
I was like we had I brought my dog in
he's like another version of meatloaf
like a really big strong German Shepherd
and I was like this is my one of my
favorite things to do I'd go on a
longboard and Tyson is this guy's name
he would pull me really fast and that's
how I'd walk him if he would pull me all
around town and it's all that baby you
gotta try it so she gets on the thing
and I and I don't think I don't think
she realized how fast Tyson can gallop
he books it starts taking off and then
just [ __ ] this is way too fast oh she
gets off the board but she didn't
prepare her legs
the minute she touched before
she flew like 20 30 feet high so had the
scars like sliding on the street
of course the boyfriend and me it's like
you it's like are you okay but the real
the real guy bleeding and he didn't even
run to me he just stayed there laughing
he wanted to run to you but the duality
of his existence is that he had to split
and it's a burden by the way paradox
yeah cuz you could see that was funny
but then you also feel bad but then
afterwards then they come for you
laughing late their blessing and a curse
to be had the duality visited true that
is it true that after he after he like
was finished Davin all his tears from
her laughing so hard that he and he
checked on you afterward yeah like the
[ __ ] Asian dad he was like and if I
loosen my belt from my good suffocating
my diaphragm
he's like ah your be alright so that's
how I know there's like you gotta take
me to the hospital cuz i bathroom he's
like I'm laughing so hard I can't
breathe submitted by Golden Horse hmm
man was arrested after he allegedly
stole his roommates ten million dollar
winning lottery ticket
we got laying around how will you get
away with this how do people always do
this [ __ ] right that's like the clerk
who's like nope
another loser yeah you know what I mean
sorry and then they're like you're gonna
meet and then they get all on camera
like who are supposed to sign it right
yeah so maybe you just didn't read that
a lot of people do that nobody reads no
one does that yeah even when you win you
don't read it can you leave that [ __ ]
have you won anything ever
I've won I won like 20 bucks from
scratch is a pretty big winner yeah hmm
so this man here he paid $30 for a
scratch-off ticket
so he thought that he won $10,000
because there was a winning ticket so he
went home he told his roommate and his
35 year old roommate means a duel he
attempted to cash in the winning
scratch-off ticket the next day at the
same lottery office this all takes place
in Sacramento by the way and so what he
ended up doing is that he went out and
he bought the same ticket what a losing
one obviously and so he switched it out
while the roommate was sleeping so
that's shady holy and the beam 10
million because he said he thought he
wanted yeah so then later on oh when the
roommate the shady roommate tried to
cash it in they were like oh you win
$10,000 you won or how many how much
yeah yeah you wanna you want a million
or ten million oh my god I can get it
yeah me too because you keep saying ten
thousand then ten million sorry it's
originally I keep thought ten thousand
uh there was ten million okay okay
calculate the winning ticket properly
when he first got it apparently not well
he is buying scratcher tickets Wow I was
a big win at 120 or maybe the original
guy he knew how shady his room it was we
didn't want to make it too big it is
mine 110 million egos oh yeah I won a
thousand bucks
cuz he knew you might get the same yeah
exactly if he knew that in a sense that
when you win ten million you bad news
got a leak out somewhere yeah tweet it
or anyone here yeah but like hey
everybody eyes one ten dollars until
it's real until it's a real ten million
in my hand I would even doubt anyone I'm
not even telling Bart the fact that it's
winning I'm just like I can't be I would
[ __ ] disappear yeah I'm telling you
this guy's like in a Coen Brothers movie
cuz he's like hey everybody I just
wanted ten thousand dollars yeah well
I'm gonna go to bed
and I'll leave it on the coffee team
yeah right I know it's like weird it's a
trap wait so what happened I got it no
so when you went in to go cashier he was
like oh no this is a losing ticket so he
was like what the hell I had a winning
ticket so then he went to the police
station and he filed a report because he
was like you know what like someone
stole me like someone switched it out
and that's how they were able to come to
a conclusion that the other roommate
tried to catch him because it was at the
same office too thank God he was done
yeah
and so they that's how so then when they
told him they'd want to fill out this
whole claim thing and then come back
later to pick up your winnings when he
went to go pick up the winnings he got
arrested wait how did they know that the
original roommate was telling the truth
maybe surveillance like what if it was
the first guy that won that much and
he's and you like because they have
records of the exact ticket number that
you received from that transaction and
it's like from this no but how do they
know
Oh cams credit card maybe these credit
cards gosh if I was the cop I'd have
been like oh yeah you had a winning
ticket you lost it you don't think I
mean you know I'd be a dick cop take the
lottery pretty seriously though cuz I
feel like every time someone wins and
then they tell a family remember a
friend like a mergers bound to happen oh
yeah I don't even let you cash it right
away - no you would they go through a
thorough investigation for anything
other or higher than $600
you have to like just claim and
everything so this is the roommate that
stole a he got charged her with grand
theft that guy looks like he steals
everything like why would you tell this
guy yeah oh man he's like I'll even
steal a kiss a kiss you know he's right
yeah he's a real thief thank you
he stole Hearts oh yeah yeah looks like
he'll steal your Forks [ __ ]
everything random missing chocolate
paper yeah anything even [ __ ] cotton
balls out of her cotton jar thing I the
idea that he replaces all of it was
something shitty is your forks with
plastic forks and then he's like no
those are just your Forks and he
replaces your cotton balls with like
rubber bands and he's like I couldn't
figure out something that was like kind
of
worse than a cotton is it get to forgive
me yeah so now they're saying that he
can be sentenced up to one year in
County Jail or up to three years in
state prison
damned wall you [ __ ] up little shady
[ __ ] what did his roomie say was he
like that shady [ __ ] probably I
want a quote yeah so I know so now the
lottery officials they were like well I
don't know we can't be certain if he's
gonna get hit the winning person if you
don't get his payment but then at the
end he concluded the email with although
I'm sure everything will work out in the
end
smiley face can you pull up his picture
again of the bad guy how would how would
they be not be sure that the winning
person could get his payment right I
know I was like that's imagine to get
the group I'm sure you will
imagine you want you just won the
lottery and then you walk up to this guy
be like hey bass what ten grand
like that's what this guy did he goes up
to that guy it tells me one time grin
like look at that [ __ ] wonder
what the victim looks like then don't
judge a book by it's cover Steve I would
even tell him that my shoes in $40 cover
the cover is pretty apparent he's a
thief he's getting a mug shot what are
you talking about rested Nicky you'll
what are you nice hating a back story
already knowing the back story if I was
a police officer and I saw this guy
walking on the street I would just
tackle him yeah happening to him all his
life so he's been like yeah people are
gonna treat me like the bad guy anyway
might as well just be a bad guy just as
mug shots just so like yeah man he's
like this is his face he's like say
something yeah he looks like he's wanted
in another country yeah that's my bad
guys
[Laughter]
yeah that guy's guilty it's like you
mean that guy you're doing a waluigi
impression yeah basically well it's
pretty good
nobody knows that reference here for you
I think that the purple suit guy yeah
yeah see what do you mean close cheetahs
wear purple suit he's from Mario's yeah
super brother Mario super brothers what
is it but you can Super Mario Brothers
clothes cute is what I'm saying
sometimes tip is in the water and she's
like where's the pool oh my god you just
nailed it completely nailed it because
the situation right think I'm in the
water I'm in the desert and everyone's
like haha she be she's in the water
[Music]